[Music]
i went in i chatted with you briefly
before the show
and uh i was thinking is such a such a
beautiful such an attractive woman i
know you're single
what are you looking for in a guy
there's guys watching right now who
think i'd love to be with chelsea
handler
really yes
um i am no i'm on the prowl i'm getting
very very horny
so i like i mean at this moment or just
in life in general
now that i sat down next to this
popsicle on a stick yeah
um i know what kind of popsicles aren't
you yeah
would you really like this no no i like
um
i think i'm in the mood for like an
accent maybe like like an english or an
irish i like irishman you like irish
guys not your type but like this
what was that that was amazing that was
me it's nice
no i like like the dark brogish kind of
you know like that
people women are always saying uh like
irish guys and then i'll say oh
really and that's one of the problems is
that i go oh really
but then they always say no i like the
dark irish the black black hair yeah
like brawny like you know like muscular
i'm kind of wait a minute what are you
talking what do you think that is right
you're
lean and muscular you are i mean yeah
you have an amazing body both of you too
yeah if you guys combined your bodies
could you imagine what kind of man that
would be
we have photos we have photos of the two
of us
combined he's just the bottom just
really long legs and then
so you like a guy with an accent just
for a little bit you know i'm not like a
long-term girl i'm not looking to get
married or have a child or anything like
that i know you're you know a family guy
i
have a big family and i'm not looking to
create any more of them
so um i just want somebody you know
maybe for a few months
and with an accent would be good so like
like a michael fassbender you know that
hot actor
yeah well what about uh you have this
show men come on the show do you ever
use your show
to try and get a date yeah that's
exactly how what i do
don't you well no you're married but
yeah i still like to you know
[Laughter]
this is on television that's what you're
known for
that's the mmo on conan that guy's on
the prowl
what uh do but seriously do you use the
show to meet guys yeah i always and
whenever i see somebody cute if i'm
single i'll say book them and then they
come on and
then i go backstage and i'm like i don't
we don't hook up backstage usually but
actually but i use that as an n i mean
that's how i meet friends that's how i
meet you know
potential lovers
no i don't do it all the time i've only
slept with like a handful of my guests
so uh don't you wish you got married
later so you could have done the same
thing or maybe i did get married a
little later and i had my time when you
know
i had people on the show and then later
on
that was me imagining them they weren't
there
just imagine there's a mop in his arms
yeah
[Laughter]
so what do you do do you say to the guy
let's say guys on your show let's say
eric estrada is on your show you
you're talking about chips and stuff
like that and then the show's over
you go to eric estrada's what do you
what do you say to these guys i just
back right into them and i say
do you want to penetrate me
it's really it's really the fastest way
to get something like that
you know on yeah just get it going you
just want to get it going
right you have to get it going and then
you can talk later and find out if you
actually really like each other i think
sexism
i think sex is more important right at
the beginning to find out what's
happening
because you don't know what's happening
you know that is important
when you say what's happening what do
you mean well a lot of things could be
happening down there that you don't know
about and you don't want to be surprised
about after you put in three weeks of
dating
okay so this is good to know so you like
to have the sex right away
and then find out like you know who are
you yeah
how did you get in here